good morning good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you are
and thank you for joining this virtual
special event live
and thank you to those of you who are
watching this event recording my name is
charles wenzel
minister councillor for food agriculture
and fisheries
at the danish embassy in washington dc
and i'll be hosting today's event
together with my good colleague tom
pesac from fao
i would like to start by thanking all of
today's speakers for taking the time
to join us in this important
conversation and also thanking all of
you
that have joined us and are listening in
we would very much like to hear from you
in the audience
to participate in our q a session that
will follow the panel discussion a
little later
please submit your questions in the chat
box
i would further like to thank our
co-organizer fao north america
thank you so much for once again making
it possible for all of us
to hone in on very important issues
concerning agriculture
we have a very busy schedule before us
today but also in
greater scheme of things so let's get
started
we are facing a growing global
population
and thereby an increasing demand for
food both plant-based and animal protein
at the same time our food systems are
being undermined
often at least in part because of impact
of management practices and land use
changes
associated with food and agriculture we
are witnessing
imminence and in some cases irreversible
biodiversity losses
in countries around the world this
alarming trend
combined with advancing climate change
as well as water scarcity
and the loss and degradation of other
vital natural resources
underscores the urgent need to
transition to a more sustainable
agricultural practices and approaches
there is a growing consensus that
greening agriculture will require new
science
and new technologies as well as new and
improved management
policies and practices farmers
has an enormous capacity to serve as
agents of change in leading a shift
towards a greener and more sustainable
agriculture for the right policies and
conditions farmers can play a lead role
in transforming
agricultural practices this policy
seminar will focus on farmers as
agents of change in the green transition
furthermore today's event is part of a
larger series of events happening
this week around the globe from asia to
europe to north america
with a center in copenhagen denmark
today and tomorrow the danish government
is hosting the annual world food summit
better food for more people this year
virtually
the sister the summit in copenhagen will
provide
important input to the un food system
summit in september
this year and key takeaways from our
event will be integrated into that
larger global agenda
today's first speaker is blimnentoshan
director of fao in north america
he will set the stage for us and then we
are honored by two excellent keynote
speakers and leaders in this field
from denmark mr cern synagogue farmer
and chairman of the danish agriculture
and food council
and from california secretary karen ross
of california department of food and
agriculture
then we will hear from three farmers and
their story of transitioning into
greener practices
mr anas narco from denmark derek acevedo
from california and doug keisling from
kansas
then there will be a panel conversation
with say tony udada
deputy director climate environment
division at the fao
thomas batchelor global vice president
of bio agriculture with nova science
north america
and martin van nuycumbe global director
for agriculture and food
at the world bank the panel will be
followed by a q a session and this event
is rounded off by blind brenter
sharan from fao but before handing the
floor to the first keynote speaker mr
cern synagogue i would like to welcome
vimenta shan director of fao brementa
the floor is yours
thank you thank you trolls and uh
let me on behalf of uh fao
food and agriculture organization north
america office welcome all of you to
what i hope will be an extremely
engaging and informative 90 minutes of
discussion
on opportunities and challenges in
quote-unquote
green transition to a more sustainable
agriculture and food practice
for me what makes the discussion more
interesting today
is that we get to hear not just from
policy makers we get to hear not just
from technical experts but
most important of all we get to hear
from the farmers
farmers who are the real agents of
change and farmers who really
bear the brunt of climate change and its
impact
now since world war ii decades since
world war ii
world agriculture has become
considerably more efficient
we have seen production system and crop
and livestock breeding programs
are resulting in significant increase in
food production
however over the same period we have
also seen that climate change
as well as the need for feeding and ever
increasing global population has
exacerbated the existing challenges
faced by agriculture
now climate change is going to have a
profound influence or rather has already
started having a profound influence
on agroecological conditions under which
farmers
and rural populations need to develop
their livelihood strategies
manage their resources and achieve food
security
and other elite food security and other
ends but towards this
and a green transition is a must
easier said than done how arduous is
that jerry how arduous is the transition
what are the challenges what are the
opportunities along the way
how do the policy makers technical
experts farmers how do they perceive it
individually
are their thought processes and thinking
in sync
now to hear and understand all this
and more around this topic we have a
fantastic collection of speakers from
which
you'll be hearing very soon but i'll be
amazed if i'm not
extremely grateful to soren van der gaad
chairman of the danish agriculture and
food council
madame kevin ross secretary department
of food and agriculture california
all our esteemed panelists from ffa
world bank
nova zones and a farm of friends joining
us from denmark california and kansas
for taking time out of um
very short extremely busy schedules to
be with us
especially those from california for
whom it must be
seven or seven thirty in the morning now
most of all
i'm also very very grateful to the
danish embassy in washington and more
specifically to
trolls minister food and agriculture and
fisheries embassy
and his colleagues for their
extraordinary effort that they have put
in
along with us and our team here at fao
north america to get this event going
and to bring this discussion to you i
will not stand in the way of some very
thoughtful and engrossing perspectives
on the issue
and let me with that hand over the
proceedings back to trolls
to take the even forward trolls
thank you so much valenta also for the
kind words but also for setting the
stage so vividly for us
and highlighting the importance of
farmers in the broader context of a food
system transformation
and now to our first keynote speaker of
the day mr sun synagogue
farmer and chairman of the maine danish
agriculture organization the danish
agriculture and food council
we are very pleased and honored that you
have taken the time to address us here
today
mr syndical the floor is yours
thank you very much trolls thank you for
the word
ladies and gentlemen good morning
everyone or
good afternoon like we say here in
denmark right now depending on where you
are
in the world it's a great honor for me
to be
attending today's webinar focusing on
this
interesting topic farmers as agents of
chains in a greening agriculture
recently the danish minister for food
and agriculture
signed a memorandum of understanding
with the department of food and
agriculture in california
focusing on further developing a climate
smart
dairy value chain so it's a special
pleasure also for me having you
secretary karen ross from california
participating here today
we are looking forward to support and
deliver
on this memorandum and make the
cooperation a success
this is exactly the kind of
international cooperation we need
for the future i honestly believe
that farmers in reality holds the key
to the future climate solutions and
could be the ones
leading the green transition towards a
more sustainable production
and in the next few minutes i will
highlight why this is the case
and i will give a danish perspective to
this very important
topic i am a farmer and i'm also
chairman of the danish agriculture and
food council
personally i run a family farm with my
wife and four kids
my main production is within pig meat
and arable crops
my family have had the farm for
generations
i took over the farm from my father and
he's still involved in the
everyday operations the organization i
represent danish agriculture and food
council
is a private organization covering the
full value chain
of agriculture and food production our
members are
the danish farmers including all sectors
and size of production organic or
conventional
members also include the food industry
cooperatives and limited companies
and on top of that the agri-industrial
sector
and companies within ingredients and
additives and
enzymes and bioenergy are members as
well
and exactly this composition in our
member base
gives us a unique opportunity to unite
the food cluster
develop strong and sustainable solutions
a complete value chain and to better
handle challenges
and opportunities integrated in our
organization
we have a strong innovation and
knowledge center called
circus this is where we get involved
in research and develop projects either
together with public research
institutions or universities or by
initiating the projects ourselves
based on present or future demands or
needs
via segas we are able to stay updated
develop more knowledge and quickly
implement it into
everyday farming or processing through
our local advisory services
in our organization danish agriculture
and food council
we have a vision of a climate neutral
agriculture and food cluster by 2050.
it's ambitious but we have a clear
target
and we are committed in getting there
we have already come quite far in living
up to the ambition
we work determined in finding
progressive solutions in the fields
in the stables and the feeding within
transportation and manufacturing and
basically in every single link of the
value chain
and it's important to identify where you
can make a change at the farm
where can you improve where can we
invest and we are determined to get
better and strengthen our farmer
management tools
we have harvested the low hanging fruits
and now it's getting
more complicated we take responsibility
and we can do a lot on our own
but we also need cooperation we need
partnerships
and we need more r d in order to get
there
and i'm sure my fellow farmer from
denmark mr
anisnergo he will give you a more
specific examples of
what we're doing at farm level a little
later in this
webinar but there's one thing
i need to underline we are dealing with
biology and many people make the mistake
to think we can
change or stop emissions from day to day
just like pushing a bottom naturally
this is not the case
everybody needs to understand that it
takes time
to change and manage a biological
process
i know the time is running and we all
want to speed up
however modern farming is getting
more and more complex and challenging
education
and knowledge sharing is fundamental for
farmers to be in a
position to live up to the expectations
from society
in denmark we have for centuries had a
strong tradition in having a specific
system for education of young farmers
all young farmers have three to four
years of education
before they become farmers themselves
another proud tradition in denmark is
our knowledge
sharing we regard our neighbors as
partners
not competitors and that is why
we have managed to build up strong
farmer-owned cooperatives
between being among the biggest
companies in denmark now
and they have world-class performance
and on top of that
as i mentioned earlier we have
established a strong advisory service
owned and controlled by farmers so we
can optimize our production
in a resource effective and sustainable
way
by sharing the latest knowledge for
example from sigis
and share it among all farmers
we engage in international cooperation
at all levels
we believe that some of the findings
some of the knowledge
the products and the solutions we have
come across in denmark
they can also lead to a more sustainable
production
elsewhere in the world
recently we have created a global
climate task force
among our members and now we are mapping
all the many ideas and solutions that
can lead the green transition
internationally it's not just about
producing
sufficient food for a growing population
anymore
we must produce and manage our farms in
an
even more sustainable manner by using
our experience
educational skills knowledge advisory
service
tradition for cooperation and our strong
value
chain approach in a coordinated and
intelligent way
we can deliver we are and always want to
be
part of the solution in handling the
future
challenges so in conclusion
what we need is first to be regarded as
partners
to be included and involved to get a
stronger commitment
secondly to get clear and consistent
signals and directions from the
politicians
so we are able to plan our investments
and our
future development thirdly to have a
more
committed public and public private r d
approach so we can develop the knowledge
the technology and the solutions we need
for the future
a fourth element is to create more
incentives for farmers
to get engaged and spark the inspiration
and motivation
a fifth point is to have a strong focus
on
developing the agriculture and food
sector
not the opposite we have to respect the
specific condition
of a biological production and finally
to increase international cooperation
and partnerships
and recognize the international impact
of promoting
new climate smart and sustainable
solutions and projects
so it is our ambition to create and
develop
an even more climate smart and
sustainable agriculture and food
production in the future
we are on our way so under the right
conditions
farmers can show an even stronger
leadership
in the green transition thank you very
much for your attention
sorry so thank you very much mr sunigo i
forgot to mute
unmute thank you for your interesting
remarks and highly relevant points
um especially on ambition for the future
education
cooperation between farmers and other
stakeholders and of course international
cooperation
and we know you have a very busy
schedule today we're honored that you
had time to to address us and i know
you'll be listening in
but thank you so much mr senegal and now
to our second keynote speaker secretary
ken ross
of cdfa we're equally honored that you
have taken the time to address us here
today
secretary ross the floor is yours
charles thank you so much
i appreciate this opportunity to be with
you today
um i really appreciated the comments
from the fao director for north america
so relevant and on point and to sauron
um
thank you he stole my speech i spent a
lot of my time
trying to tell lawmakers in california
that the challenges in farming are that
we have to recognize that they are
managers of a biological system
and if you change one thing it's all
interconnected and so
i really appreciate that now i know that
my next climate smart ag trip is going
to be to denmark because i want to meet
you in person thank you
my friend and former boss and now
current secretary of the united states
department
of agriculture recently said
i think agriculture is the first and
best way
to begin getting some early wins on
climate
i think he's absolutely right i've seen
it i've seen it in california
and i've seen it around the globe i'm
really pleased that we're having farmers
here today and so i am going to be very
brief
in my remarks but the very fact that the
theme of this
is a focus on farmers and ranchers
as ages of change is exactly where we
all need to focus and i think that a
year
after a pandemic when we all feel maybe
a bit more
directly connected to our dinner plate
there is a
renewed appreciation for the role of
farmers and ranchers in our daily life
and the opportunity to create new
partnerships
and new collaborations is the only way
that we will be successful because we as
government cannot do it alone
academia can't do it alone farmers and
ranchers can lead on change but they
should not be expected to do it
and bear that responsibility alone
it requires all of us working together
to be able to share what we know works
to be able to learn from one another and
to
innovate in the ways that i believe the
next chapter
of agriculture in this globe will be an
exciting one because of the innovation
that is being unleashed on a daily basis
through ag technology and other new
systems approaches
the whole commitment to building a
resilient
sustainable food system one
that nourishes people and nourishes them
better
one that is equitable and makes sure
that every human
has the food they need to achieve their
potential
and be contributors to society a
a resilient food system that is part
of restoring our ecosystems
and preserving species and biodiversity
i've seen firsthand that that is
possible and yes
soren is right it is up to government to
give the appropriate policy signals
not to be overly prescriptive to be able
to recognize that we all
operate on the place where we are that
it is our farmers and ranchers
and their farm workers who have been on
this land for generations
and every day think about how to hand it
on to the next generation and the one
after that
they are the ones that know that land
and as stewards of our natural and
working lands
they can be the agents of change that we
all know and want them to be
so it is our role in government to first
of all give the appropriate policy
signals
we've recognized that throughout
governments by setting our own
climate goals in california as a state
our goal is to be carbon neutral by 2045
and we recognize with a natural working
land strategy
that is going to be the key for us to be
successful
that it is in agriculture and in
forestry
the opportunity to draw down carbon and
store it in our soils
and in doing so and focusing on our
healthy soils
we can be more productive we can be more
drought tolerant
with a water holding capacity we can
improve the efficient use of fertilizer
by improving the nutrient cycling and we
will be resilient over time
we have in just the last few years
invested
just in my department over 400 million
dollars
that have been made available to us as
incentive programs because
we use a cap and trade system and those
auction proceeds are being reinvested
into transitioning our economy to carbon
neutral
in total over the last 10 years almost 1
billion dollars has been invested in a
variety of programs
to benefit farmers and ranchers in
making this transition
at the department of food and
agriculture one of our largest programs
has been for the dairy sector
to reduce methane emissions very
important
and in doing that the co benefit of that
is improved water quality
by by mitigating nitrates and
also by producing renewable energy
whether it's electricity
low carbon fuels or renewable natural
gas
we've invested over 50 million dollars
in the last three years in our healthy
soils program
and over a 10-year period we've invested
over 80 million dollars for on-farm
water use efficiency
which also has the co-benefit of
reducing energy use reducing greenhouse
gases
and improving the efficiency of our
nitrogen applications
governments working together governments
coming together and sponsoring forums
like this one and the world food summit
and the un
food system dialogues is an opportunity
for us to share those best practices
to learn which policies work and how
they might be adapted for our own
country
and our own state i'm excited to hear
from our farmers and ranchers today
i am so appreciative and every day i say
a prayer of gratitude for our farmers
and ranchers
for what they do for all the rest of us
so that we can live the lives of our
choices
and not have to worry i hope about where
our food comes from and we can feel good
about what farmers and ranchers are
doing because of the way in which
they're producing it
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions to
store
carbon in our soils to use water as
efficiently as possible
and to be as part of the solution in
preserving biodiversity
and restoring our ecosystems it is
possible
i have seen it i believe it and we're
going to hear from farmers who will give
us
daily examples of how to do it thank you
thank you thank you so much madam
secretary
for your always inspiring and insightful
remarks
and to your points on that agriculture
is you know local in nature
but it has global consequences and your
calls for action and cooperation
internationally
i would say we are looking very much
forward to hosting you in denmark
sometime
soon as i'm transitioning home i will be
there and i greet you
i know you have a busy day uh but we are
very honored that you
know took the time and got up early to
address us here and i hope you will
have have a chance to listen into some
of the some of the next speakers
so once again thank you so much for
being with us and now we turn to the
farmers
the steward of the lands and of the
animals first off is mr annas nargo
a dairy farmer from denmark and he's
also the vice president of holster
borussoa
agriculture council we are very
interested in hearing your story
how and when began the green transition
on your farm and what has made it
possible
mr nargo the floor is yours
thank you very much and thanks for
inviting me for this
uh webinar as we have a slogan in
denmark
danny's farmers talk about we don't
we are part of the solution not the
problem so i think it fit
pretty well in here i have made a
short presentation because my english is
not perfect so if
you can't understand what i'm saying
then i hope the pictures will do the ch
uh the the point for me
but as said my name is anas i'm a dairy
farmer from
the western part of denmark we have
about 850 cows and about 750 hives
we are milking primarily all the cows in
12 laylee milking robots
we have about 475 hectares of land
only with grace and maize for the cows
beside of that we have a
biogas plant and as you said toads i'm a
board member of
the local farmers union and i'm a board
member of
landford cattle
um i've been asked to tell a bit about
what we are doing sustainable today at
the farm
and i just made four slides about the
first things come to my head
we do a lot of small things as farmers
who are sustainable but this is a far
four
four things who's come first to my head
in 2018 we were building a biogas plant
at our own just in the end of the stable
it is today that means that we don't
have trucks
or similar to transporting the
manure we are just pumping it directly
from the stables into the
burgers plant the biogas plant is
producing about five and a half
million kilowatts electricity a year
it's the same as six times the
consumption of the farm
electricity or in other terms about 1200
houses
it runs primarily at manure and deep
leader from the farm
and the neighbor and at the moment we
have some waste from the
indrostial about for example we have
bread as you see in the picture that's
pretty funny every day we have a
truckload
and we also run some potatoes who can't
be sold
sold because of the covenant
situation it makes
also better utilization for the
of the nitrogen especially for the deep
leader but also the manure but at the
dip later we've moved for about 45
to about 75 so that's uh pretty
sustainable we think
the next thing um as some talked about
we have a lot we have a long history in
denmark about
working together in the whole food
cluster and we are very proud
to have today to have the digital feed
chain
where we can measure uh all the steps
between the field
and the mill tank and if we are
following
following the pictures then in the left
corner we have the chopper
at the field it's connecting to the
cloud and the database
so with gps and near sensors we can
measure the production at the field all
the time
we are going into the silo and the
database of course the third picture is
from
our wheel loader where we have a tablet
solution
connecting in real time to the database
so it makes all the registration about
the food
and all this is ending up in a daily
feeding region for the cows
the good thing about that is the
database because we have all these
measurements
uh the database is making uh
automatically
efficiency report every day that means
for us
as farmers that we can go closer to the
limits so we have a better economy
for first point they caught their
feeding is the biggest cost at the farm
but we also have better
real resource utilization of the food
and third we have better health so what
can be measured can be changed
the next thing is about the climate
check
we have from ala our dairy company
climate calculation can be very advanced
and we have a big need
as farmers for similar calculations so
we can
move at this agenda
that's why we in allah have a annual
report
and it makes that we can see the
consequence of our actions
it's a very strong benchmark database
with about eight and a half thousand are
owners in five countries i think
so we have a lot of benchmark data to
benchmark
us against and we also once a year have
a visit by an advisor
where we are only discussing in this
case the climate issues
and where we could do better than today
the next thing is about our hood
we have a cross-breeded herd it's not so
normal in denmark
but we are cross-breeded our herd
between holstein red
and jersey and research shows that it
makes a six percent lower feed intake of
the cows
that's pretty easy it's just to insulate
with another
with another genes and research
also shows that we have better health
and the cows lived
longer so that's one of the things was
coming to my mind
at the next slide i was asked
what is it that
how do we get the farmers more
sustainable and what are you thinking
about and and we always been told that
the
gold is licensed to produce in my head
it have to be higher than license to
produce first of all
we are a company we have to earn money
if we don't earn money and we don't have
a strong economy
we can instil we can't invest in all the
green technologies
now and in the future so that's the main
cause
of course i'm also very important for me
to secure the company for the future in
a sustainable way
happily most of the things we are doing
improve both the economy
and its sustainable solution
so to get farming more sustainable in
the future
will require a better economy in farming
and a more stable political environment
thank you for listening
you so much mr nago very interesting
remarks
and uh very nice to see some concrete
examples of sustainable practices
you know the climate check program and
your points on on biogas
but i think also the correlation between
efficiency and making money
you have a family farm that needs to run
and secure for for you and your family
in the future
i think very interesting thank you so
much and please stay on and listen into
the
to the next ones and now we turn to
central valley
california where we'll hear remarks from
derek acevedo
executive vice president of boltz
farming company mr astava is part of a
sixth generation farm
where they produce cotton vegetables
fruits and nuts among other things
mr altaverdo how does bold farming
overcome the challenges
as modern farming are facing and how
have you made the transition
in central valley mr acevedo the floor
is yours
thank you yes and and uh bowles farming
company is a 162 year old farming
operation where the same family has
stewarded that land
the entire time and there's there's an
incredible sustainability story that
comes with that and during
that transition uh the the organizations
have the opportunity to reinvent itself
multiple times
and um you know one of the things that
that you can fall into is a lot of us
focus on providing
nutrient-dense foods for our food shed
and
and and and the consumers that we touch
and then and as it relates to the
the green transition you know my
my mark for that really begins when when
our current ceo ken and michael really
looked at
um you know the the simple fact that our
consumers are
asking for more than they're asking more
of their food than just to produce their
nutritional needs
and and asked us as the management team
to look at the farm a little bit
from a broader perspective you know you
can fall into the rut
of just growing stuff but if you look at
the farm as an opportunity to be a
carbon sink to draw down
excess carbon from the atmosphere if you
look at the farm as an opportunity to
grow habitat
and provide uh habitat for
the the birds and terrestrial species we
have on the farm you know that that
caused us to start a california native
seed company where we grow 52 different
species of
of california native plants that help
provide habitat for the local ecosystem
the farm is also a place to grow our
people as simple as it may sound you
know
investing in scholarship opportunities
for
for our employees strengthens our
community and helps provide resilience
to our
our community and the customers that we
serve um
perhaps most importantly you know our
farm serves as
you know a laboratory a place for
research we we've aggressively pursued
some of the uh climate smart initiatives
that that
that secretary ross has fought so hard
for and and we invite
multiple stakeholders multiple
partnerships with ngos and biologists
and all sorts of different individuals
to come to the ranch and actually
advance the technologies that we have
we've been on a
continuous transition all of agriculture
has
with producing more food with fewer
inputs
over time and so one of the most
exciting parts of
of this green transition is to witness
some of that
cross-pollination between the technology
of agriculture
applied to native plants and the native
plants you know
forcing their way onto some of our
agricultural fields and
and offer offering opportunities
potentially for food as medicine
and even participating in the in the
textile industry and so
you start to bring in some of our ngo
friends you bring in some of the
biologists the water you get a chance to
to broaden your scope and and for all of
those reasons and we can get into more
of the
the the opportunities and and challenges
a little bit later in the discussion but
but for all of those reasons you know
it's been um you know it's been
incredibly exciting
to be a part of and and um you know
agriculture is one of those that
that uh when you when you take that that
that more zoomed out approach
to to looking at the farm is more than
just the place to grow stuff
you know the the opportunities are
endless and it's probably the most
exciting business to be a part of in the
world today
all right thank you so much but derek
for that i think uh
that was very interesting points uh you
made there on the farms and the
practices
and great points about consumer
expectation local ecosystem
r d incorporation and a broaden scope
for
ag in the future thank you very much
and now we will move uh from the west
coast to the heartlands to kansas
our next speaker is mr doug keisling mr
kiesling is the fifth generation farmer
who has been involved in almost all
aspects of farming from crop production
to supply chain services and policy
mr kiesling what is your experience in
growing greener
and more sustainable and what are your
recommendations to farmers and policy
makers
mr kiesling the floor is yours
thank you so much and welcome to all of
you i know that
if you're a producer you had several
options today to get on other zoom calls
to learn about sustainability and
how to grow carbon for profit and
different other things so i'm glad that
you're here on this one
um if you're a policymaker and all you
know this is an
opportunity that i can reach out to you
and talk to you about our farm and how
this works in the bigger picture first
of all let me start and back up he told
a little bit about my
farm our farm started in 1876 so i'm a
fifth generation farmer central
kansas central united states rainfall
here is 20 to 24 inches of rain
so a lot less than some areas our top
soil
and you think i might be crazy but we
only have one inch of topsoil compared
to an iowa or an illinois or even
central valley california
so we take our conservation very serious
here
because we can't afford to lose any so
some of the practices that we do are
focused on them
um to wrap up our farm history we are
right on the santa fe trail where i'm
sitting right here
is smack dab in the middle of the santa
fe trail
so there's a huge amount of history and
this was homesteaded before uh
for before my family by a doctor so on
our farmstead
are a lot of native plants not only to
the midwest
but from other areas for municipal
purposes
that the doctor used so because of that
come with this rich history
of what it takes to make the full circle
of the biologicals now
on our farm we've been doing no-till or
sustainability for
30 years now keep that in mind because
that's seven administrations that
started in reagan
and has come all the way through seven
administrations so when we talk about
this
it's nothing new it's been going for
quite a while
but on our farm we do everything from
conservation
manure management with it which includes
adding a lot of manure to our land
instead of chemical fertilizers
we do integral grazing to where we will
graze different times in different
fields
so i don't really have pastures we use
our cropland
and rotate that around also but we do it
with
sources of using our crops which we have
seven different crops plus our livestock
about 200 head of cattle in in a full
system of approach and with biologicals
the cover crops
some cover crops are used in portion of
the grazing
some of it is used just for organic
building particularly if we took over a
new piece of ground
where we're helping we do custom work
through our business and if we're
helping someone build organic matter
just to get started
we start them and help them get started
in a plan
of building organic matter to capture
that carbon to start with
um i want to back up and talk about some
terms we all think we know what it is
but even in the ag industry we struggle
sometimes with the terms
so we talk about carbon sequestering
what does that really mean
does that mean for me and what i just
said that i'm leaving residue on the
field or i'm planning a cover crop
that will just be mowed in or planted
into
probably because we want to capture that
carbon for for later on and we want to
build that organic matter and that one
inch of topsoil i talked about
sustainability man i think we all
probably on this whole call we have 800
different
opinions of sustainability so we need to
that's one goal that agriculture really
has is how can we define some of these
and
encircle them in so that when we're
talking to
you know the secretary of agriculture or
our legislators how can we
make a rifle point of this is the exact
point that we want to talk about with
sustainability
um how do how do we do that um
you know well we have to build habitat
uh one of the other
speakers talked about habitat and
grasses i i
hunt but i do it more
my habitat is for water quality because
i want to make sure that the water
flowing off my farm
is cleaner than when it started
a lot of times it'll come in from
someone else it com goes across me
and when it leaves i want to make sure
that that water is clean
the other thing is we farm about 3 000
hectares which
or or do custom work on which is about 7
500 acres
and so with that we have gone to where
when my grandfather two generations back
he farmed a lot of 20 acre strips in
order to do
wind erosion or water erosion we now
plant
the whole quarter or half section so we
might have 320 acre fields now
whereas he had 20 or 40 acre fields in
strips
but by doing this new technology by
doing research we found
that we can do this and we can capture
the water make the water cleaner
and keep wind erosion down
how do i want to talk about some of the
partners that we haven't talked about
as a farmer i view several partners key
within this
they might be ngos like i serve on the
board of
cultivating new frontiers in ag a large
ngo in dc
and we do stuff all around the world but
part of that is
then we do research somewhere else as
i'm traveling
uh to multiple international countries
and then i bring it back to my farm and
i improve my farm too
and then i perfect it and then i take it
back internationally
to some other country to make that
better as i'm doing consulting in
another country
so that's a partner to me um community
commodity organizations are a huge
partner
because you know in in kansas wheat and
sorghum
and some other crops are the big crops
and so wheat and sorghum have done
a lot of research in order to how to
figure out which
is the best way to do conservation
tillage how to
transition over to no-till how to use
these tools that we talked about
and they've also done a lot in order to
make sure that our environment's better
to where we can take our crops to make
ethanol so
that's the renewable source how we can
use
carbon neutral crops in order to sell i
even sell part of my wheat that goes to
the east coast right by dc
to make carbon neutral beer and so you
know
it's all part of the situation of what
can we do to make it better
um we need the more technology one of
the things i struggle with
is using less fertilizer a synthetic
fertilizer for like nitrogen
i use manure but that's one of the
things that you know i still need help
with on more research
in order to to get over that hurdle so i
can raise more crops with less
fertilizer
a lot of the things we do that also
helps with water retention
i've already kind of talked on that some
of the concerns that agriculture in the
midwest have
is the cost versus the return ratio
for me to implement some of these
practices it might cost 40.
an acre and currently my return may be
half that
and so as we uh talk about bills or
legislation or just trend lines
how can we incentivize farmers to do
more
they already want to do it and i'm
already doing things that cost me money
more than make me money
but i'm doing it because it's the right
reason i want to do it for my
environment i
drink the water here so i want to make
sure that it's better
than what it was when i started and then
the other thing is
is i travel so much um the one key thing
that's hard that's a challenge that is
weather you know here i'm getting 20
some inches
in west texas it might be five inches so
they have a hard time raising a cover
crop
and raising a crop also so things like
crop insurance
and all these things we think doesn't
affect climate smart
activities but they do uh because it
affects the farmers bottom line and how
do we move forward
so all of these things and this is a lot
to put in
seven or eight minutes here but that's
kind of what we do and
i hope to have questions later thank you
thank you very much mr keising for those
interesting perspectives
um and yeah please stay on i'm sure
there will be some questions for you
um some interesting perspectives on
conservation and soil manure use
crop rotation and how farms are
integrated in the local biology
and of course also on your points on
knowledge sharing and partnerships
so thank you so much and now um
and before i hand over the floor to tom
pasek who will be moderating the panel
discussion and in the q
s session i would like to remind the
audience
that we would very much like to hear
from you i know there's a few questions
in the chat box but please submit some
more
questions there and then uh tom will uh
will take them up during the the q a
session so tom
over to you
excellent thank you trills i think we've
heard an excellent
series of remarks uh very insightful
remarks from chairman sundergard
in denmark and secretary ross in
california
and of course from our farmers uh
hailing from denmark and the united
states
in this portion of our event we will
hear more of an international
or a global perspective on some of the
key challenges
and opportunities associated with
farmers serving
as agents of change in greening
agriculture
and we have the very good fortune of
being joined for this panel discussion
by three prominent
thought leaders in this space and i
would like to turn first to my fao
colleague
cytonie old donna is deputy director
of the climate environment division
based typically at fao headquarters in
rome
i believe today he is joining us from
the uk
tony welcome thank you tell us that
could you tell us a bit about how fao is
supporting
farmers as agents of change in greening
agriculture
and how farmers are being engaged in the
global climate agenda
to help achieve the goals of the paris
climate agreement
and the broader 2030 agenda
well thank you and um greetings everyone
from wherever you are
this is really very interesting
discussion and i haven't listened to
to the colleagues who spoke already um
it it's good to to see the perspective
from from those parts of the world
um so let me start by um answering
your question by looking at the global
agenda yeah in fao
we're supporting farmers at two
um fronts if you like the first one is
on the global agenda exactly as you said
because globally
um there are various initiatives and
policies being put in place that will
affect
farmers will affect the future of
farming so it's important that farmers
are part of that dialogue
part of how the future of farming is
being
framed is being um influenced and
and and challenged and particularly
on the international climate change
agenda on the u.n framework conventional
climate change and the implementation of
paris agreement
uh with support farming communities
actually to come to the negotiation to
see what it's like to see what is being
discussed
and to give them the opportunity to have
a voice actually to
to say what are the challenges
they're facing and what are the issues
that they would like to see really been
addressed to achieve
this sustainability that we talk about
to achieve the transition
and the point i want to make here with
this global action is that you know
the discussion we've been hearing and
and the views so far
um i would like to add one dimension in
particular which which we haven't
covered
and and that of the smallholder farmers
you know we spoke a lot about
farmers who have capacities and
knowledge etc
but 98 of the world's agricultural
holdings
are 10 hectares or less
and most of these smallholder farmers
are in developing countries
and you support around two billion
people
so it's really critical that when we
talk about the change that we
when the sustainability we need to
include smallholder farmers
in sub-saharan africa and south asia in
particular we have 80
about 80 percent of farmland is
cultivated by smallholder farmers
so this is really critical to include
this
this um community of farmers so the
second point i want to make
um is with regard to support in fact i
talked about the global agenda and
bringing farmers to where they need to
voice their concerns and their
priorities
and their wishes but the second point is
supporting actually
farmers in their countries to adopt um
climate smart practices but also as some
of the colleagues said
to have access to the knowledge to the
information those farmers who actually
would
benefit from from access to technology
from innovation
and here again i want to highlight the
point of when we talk about
innovation and technology and supporting
farmers
we shouldn't forget about the local
knowledge the traditional the indigenous
knowledge
and that's absolutely critical because
um
farmers do learn from each other and the
knowledge just transfers from generation
to generation from community to
community
so i hope this gives an overview of tom
and give a chance to other
colleagues to to come in and happy to
come back and add more information thank
you
thanks i juni if if i could just like to
ask a follow-up question i think in this
session
we've been hearing quite a lot about how
uh
if we're to address the the climate
challenges we face
we can't forget about agriculture and
you've just reminded us that
in considering and addressing
agriculture we can't forget about
smallholder farmers
within that could you talk a bit about
the role
and the importance of of youth of young
farmers
and especially women
yes absolutely well i think um you know
we
we think about the fact that if you want
to achieve and i think this is the point
to take away
if you want to achieve this
transformation in agriculture we cannot
do it without involving farmers
it's absolutely critical but looking
into the future of farming and
where actually um you know the the
communities can be more active we can't
exclude the youth particularly in some
parts of the world
where the population is is very young
and take the example of africa for
instance and i think we have to take
that into account into looking into the
future of agriculture
and the role of youth is critical but
the
challenge the biggest challenge there is
how would you make
agriculture attractive to young people
you know how would you bring uh young
people into the
in into this profession and as you know
in many areas there is um
there is a problem in rural areas where
young people are fleeing the rural areas
to go to
to live in in in urban areas
and that creates of course problems in
in the rural areas and also
creates the lack of capacity
in in taking up um profession in
agriculture
so there needs to be incentives in in
in terms of creating investment
opportunities in helping young people
to have access to finance there are so
many entrepreneurs who have ideas they
want to create
things in in rural environments but they
need that financial support and i'm
talking particularly
in developing countries and women in
particular i think the biggest challenge
either young or otherwise is the land
tenure
uh particularly in developing countries
i think colleagues have been talking
here about you know the
establishment of farms that you have
with the size etc
and the capacity been in many developing
countries unfortunately there are many
small holders
whole all the farmers in particular um
to whom the land is is not their
property and that's again a huge
challenge in really contributing to food
security
and land protection without being the
owner of of
um of the land the last point i would
make tom is
is really with regard to inequality
uh that's again with regard to to youth
and and and women
it's absolutely critical that the issue
of inequality is addressing these
settings so that the
access to technology access to finance
is is is really uh available to everyone
and is
is affordable by everyone and the point
the reason i'm saying this is because if
we really want to achieve
global sustainability then we have to
address equality of access to knowledge
to
to to technology to the resources that
are needed
thank you thanks so much
and please don't go far from your your
laptop i'm sure we'll be turning to you
momentarily during the q and a
i'd now like to introduce martian van
nuke
global director of agriculture and food
at the world bank
martin we've heard uh quite a bit about
the importance of
um farmers and their role in catalyzing
a transition to greener and more
sustainable agriculture and i think that
that
inherently assumes that they're
sufficiently empowered
or equipped to do so and zytonia just
touched upon
the question of finance and and given
your role at the bank
at the world bank i was wondering if you
could uh
talk to us about the bank's assessment
of the relevance of current
public support to agriculture and and
in enabling farmers to serve as agents
of change
thanks very much thomas i'm very pleased
to be here
um and just for the sake of transparency
you know originally i'm from the
netherlands and i actually grew up on a
family horticulture farm in the western
part of the netherlands so i'm very
pleased to be here with all the farmers
still very strong roots there um i i
think
i i think i mean anders was talking
about
i mean we need stable policies i think
syria was talking about we need clear
signals from governments
and derek was mentioning you know i mean
the importance of incentives
um so if you if you kind of look at that
i mean um
based on the data the best data that we
have i mean governments across the
world i mean provide about 700 billion
dollars in public support i mean to
agriculture i mean this is a big
amount of resources so the question then
is you know what is that doing for
farmers
um a couple of reflections there uh
thomas one is that
you know most of that support i mean
does doesn't end up i mean with a small
hold of farmers
c2 usa actually most actually ends up
with the larger
farmers um a big chunk
is about 300 billion is provided for
market and price support and output
support uh this generates a lot of
allocative efficiencies actually
providing incentives to farmers to grow
crops that actually shouldn't grow and
better they should grow something else i
mean think about farmers growing rice in
the punjab in
india a lot of public support also going
to input subsidies
that also leads actually to overuse of
fertilizers
and that creates all kinds of
environmental problems and of course
doesn't actually
help the farmers bottom line electricity
subsidies for
pumping irrigation water i mean depletes
groundwater tables that actually forces
farmers
to invest in pumps i mean that pump of
water deeper and deeper
and actually thereby is undermining
their resilience
also one could argue that if you look at
fertilizer subsidies
to what extent are they actually
relevant if you factor in
the uh the risks the increasing risk of
climate change i mean what's the value
of a fertilizer subsidy the farmer
doesn't have anything to sell
because his crop is destroyed because of
a drought i mean what's the value
of a minimum price i mean for certain
crop of the farmer it doesn't have any
to sell because
of a heat wave so so our assessment is
i mean that this 700 billion dollars i
mean can be used much better
i mean actually to incentivize i mean
farmers to invest in greener
more sustainable technologies that also
that actually reduce greenhouse gas
emissions i mean can this
700 billion be repurposed and that's a
very
important point that we actually are
bringing up globally thomas
as part of the food system summit i mean
that the un
is working on the bank is very active in
the finance level of that
i mean to think of a kind of a new food
finance architecture for the global food
systems
where farmers have clear incentives i
mean to invest in green technologies and
sustainable practices
back to you thomas
thanks martin you touched upon the
question of incentives and
you talked about some of the
opportunities
uh on the horizon uh to to support and
further enable farmers i was wondering
if you could elaborate a bit more
as you look out across the international
agricultural development
landscape or or horizon if you will
could you tell us what excites you in in
terms of the opportunities
before us to help empower and equip
farmers to
effectively serve as agents of change in
in greening agriculture
yeah a couple of reflections here thomas
i mean one is
the discussion about just about just
rural transition
um there was launch after the un climate
action summit in 2019
i think that's very important you know
because this this there's something
strange going on here and i think it was
also reflected
when you listen to our farmer colleagues
that farmers are kind of be singled out
as being part of the problem
and farmers want to be part of the
solution you know if you talk about just
a transition
you know the way coal miners are being
projected
in the public opinion is not as being
part of the problem they're being seen
as victims and we need to help them
while farmers actually um you know
we need to you know human mankind i mean
7.5 billion people they're all affected
by
climate change but the 500 million
farmers in this world
are actually in the front line of
climate change i mean so
how can we actually help them and
incentivize i mean to kind of make sure
that they can actually help
deal with the climate change because in
the end i mean the 75
the 7.5 billion people depend on what
farmers do when it comes to access to
food etc so
so given farmers voice i think that
needs to be improved i think the just
drool transition initiative
i mean provides opportunities uh there i
already mentioned the
shift in incentives i mean particularly
now with covet 19
i think governments are forced to take a
very hard look at the public support
programs everywhere in all sectors
including in agriculture
so i see a kind of opening up of
ministers of finance including at the
spring meetings that we had last week
and seeing actually how they can use
public support to agriculture and food
more smartly
um i mean why are we why are we
subsidizing fertilizers i mean why are
we not providing incentives to farmers
i mean to invest in soil health i mean
why is the
price of carbon the market price of
carbon uh ten dollars while the
uh shadow price the opportunity cost of
uh carbon
is estimated by the imf at seventy
dollars at all i mean
imagine if that would be seventy dollars
at all what kind of incentive that would
be required
and then finally uh what farmers need
uh and i think the the the the secretary
of agriculture of california mentioned
it as well
i mean they're managers of biological
systems though so solutions
do not call me silver bullets solutions
do not come as
blueprints i mean they come in packages
and those packages need to be adjusted
i mean to local conditions so investing
in agriculture innovation more applied
research
and adapted research and better
knowledge transfer systems
are needed and idea and then i'm
optimistic thomas i mean that the
digital
technologies and the digital revolution
and digital and data driven agriculture
provides new opportunities there
to transform the food system back to you
and thank you very much martin and
you've made my job quite easy
in providing the perfect segue to our
last panel speaker but uh certainly
certainly not the least
and uh i'd like to now introduce thomas
batchelor who's the vice president
of agriculture marketing and strategy at
novosimes and
i'm hoping that thomas can take us on a
tour or a visit to the laboratory
as it were thomas martin just mentioned
uh the importance of research
i was hoping you could talk a bit about
the role of
research and science and innovation in
helping to create the enabling
conditions
for farmers to effectively serve as
agents of change in
ushering in more sustainable agriculture
and
of course within that tell us of course
the the role of
novozymes in achieving this
yeah i'll be happy to thank you and i
think it is a perfect segue
from all the other speakers here because
over time we are
a global market leader in developing
biological solutions for the broader
agriculture and food value chain
and and our controlling shareholder is
is a foundation of a foundation that
also reinvests a lot of our proceeds
back into fundamental research
in in this area so it is it's very much
our vision to be driving this innovation
so what we are focused on is is really
this biological system we all talked
about
unlocking the potential of that nature
if we look at the comment from
people who talk about applying manure
back to the field
understanding that microbiome so the
natural microbes that are in
the soil and in the manure you take a
teaspoon of soil
it comprises microbes that exceed the
number of people on the planet it's a
incredibly complex system and the
potential of just
unlocking what nature already has holds
tons of potential so what we're looking
at
is developing those microbes and enzymes
which are
natural compounds as well and applying
them for
agriculture at an industrial scale so
growers can apply them
and they can be adopted as a natural
part of agricultural practices
also for livestock farming a similar the
microbiome within
a cattle and so forth is also one of the
ways we can succeed for solutions
the methane reduction that was
maintained for for dairy and cattle
a lot of potential for that and and
that's exactly what novosymes
is driving and investing very heavily
and to succeed
enabling a more sustainable agriculture
of the future
and if i can allow just kick-starting
the reflection on some of the things i
hear here because i think it was perfect
comment on
this incentives which i think just
looking at the real value that's
provided for not only our solutions but
others making sure we create
a real marketplace that that creates a
profit for pharma applying the right
practice is one thing
but i think there's an even simpler
starting point allowing a route to
market for new innovation
that is more expedited so we have safe
and proven
solutions that are spot on for some of
the agendas we are talking about today
but it still takes five to ten years to
get them there because
we're going into the pre-existing
chemical regulatory frameworks often uh
that we think we can find ways of
enabling a faster way to market and to
the growers hands
just by having more of the fast track
mindset
using some of the cobit experience if we
really want solutions to the market
we can cut the time to get them there
and i think that's part of the solution
that i would
argue should be seen as as a way forward
excellent thank you thomas and if i may
i'd like to ask a bit of a follow-up
question
number zymes of course is is widely
recognized
as a leader in providing and developing
sustainable solutions for the
agricultural
biological industry particularly in
developing solutions that contribute to
solving
the global challenges related to climate
and water
and production as well as consumption
and so within that could you just
elaborate a bit more i know you've
uh touched upon some solutions but
within all of this
could you elaborate a bit on novozyme's
perspective in terms of
some of the biggest challenges and
opportunities you see
perhaps over the next 10 years
yeah i think the greatest opportunity is
is to make sure that that we get
innovation
in the hands of farmers and get it
widely adopted and that's a mix
of the incentives and the path to market
and then
realize making both growers but but also
policy makers
aware that technology actually already
has
solutions that can kick start some of
the changes we have
but as in many cases there's a huge
benefit for accelerating that adoption
in various ways and we're already
partnering with
there was a mention of sega's trying to
have these partnerships where industry
like ourselves partner with both growers
and organizations to make sure it's not
seen as a
corporate push of profit but it's a
solution that's adopted broadly from
policy makers growers
and industry as partners i think that
that will unlock a lot of value and if
we're a little bit creative about
combining incentives helping growers
decipher a very complex technology so
getting some validity
from an unbiased side i think that
adoption can be
accelerated hugely to the benefit of all
the targets we're talking about
excellent thank you thomas and to our
audience thank you for your
excellent engagement and and patience
we're now turning to
the question and answer portion of our
event
and i see we still have almost all of
our speakers still with us
i would now based upon what's been
posted in the
q a box by our audience by way of
questions i would now like to
turn quickly back to our three farmers
and to ask them each uh very briefly
to talk about what they see as the big
opportunities uh
in engaging young farmers uh in this
transition and
perhaps talking a bit more about
incentives so perhaps if i could start
with uh with derek
thank you um you know as i mentioned
agriculture is one of the most exciting
fields on
on the planet and a lot of the
technology that's been introduced
uh to agriculture over the last hundred
years has provided opportunities for
non-traditional roles on the modern farm
we know we've had a
a position on our on our management team
the vice president of technology for the
last five years
we have a biologist we have you know we
have
um you know different food safety folks
and we've pulled people from other
industries
into our farm to to broaden our
perspective but at the same time provide
opportunities for folks that
you know they never saw their their role
as
as being working with a farm but the
the data management that we go through
the analysis that we go through i mean
farming is a science-based profession
you know the modern food supply is is
grown by agronomists
you know biologists chemists pest
control advisors all these different
science professions that provides a lot
of opportunity
for um for young people to to enter the
role of farming and
to speak briefly about about incentives
you know i thought about
you know how how do we simply define
the you know the role of the policy
makers and and the opportunity
uh that we have by showcasing the voice
of the farmer and what i came up with
was you know the
the implementation and the success of
of meaningful policy will simply be
judged based on
the ability to provide rewards to the
private land steward who protects the
public good
thank you derek i'd now like to turn to
doug uh very briefly if you could uh
respond to the same question
sure i think there's a couple of
different things some of the more
logical ones is help through
organizations like 4-h or ffa for future
farmers
i have two high school boys my two
oldest kids are in high school
and they both belong to those two
organizations and i've learned
quite a bit there one of the things i'd
like to highlight is my 16 year old son
was offered some land to farm and
from an older farmer and he could not
do it because the rules under our us
f um through our government
uh say that because he's under 18 he
can't have it in his name
so the farmer had to turn it over to me
now granted he's going to be
i'm going to make sure that he's
actively involved in helping but
sometimes we're our owners
worst enemy is what i want to point out
thank you very much doug and i don't
believe um
our unders are our danish farmer is uh
is still with us um so i won't uh turn
to him but if i could
i would like if possible to pose a
question from the audience
to secretary ross um which comes from
cecile makani and the question has to do
with whether it's possible
to have effective partnerships between
farmers
in developing countries and those in
developed countries
such as the united states
i think it's possible there was a time
in in us
history where we funded organizations to
do exactly that kind of farmer to farmer
um transfer and i think doug mentioned
he's had an opportunity through his
organization
to travel the world and take his
research to other parts of the world
i think it's absolutely vital to what
we're doing i think it can happen farmer
to farmer but i also
think the investment that's made in the
u.s we're very fortunate to have
the cooperative extension system which
is publicly funded
that third-party objective source of
doing trials
and then sponsoring demonstration days
for a group of farmers to learn from one
another
and i think that is an important place
when i look at the world
at the world bank i think that is an
important incentive that is the research
that is that transfer of knowledge and i
know that our cooperative extension
even though it's underfunded from what
it once was is still the envy of the
world because it's helping
to do that transfer of knowledge and
translating in a way that the end user
from the smallest to the largest for
animal and for crops and i think
these are the types of things we need to
think about globally and
lobby our own governments to make those
kinds of investments
as well thank you very much
secretary um i don't believe we still
have
chairman's undergrad with us so i won't
pose the same question to him but
i could i'd like to turn to our three
panelists from the world bank
fao and novo zimes uh perhaps in that
order
uh martin uh zytuni
and then thomas the question we have
here comes from
ernie shea and ernie indicates
that it's often hard to understand
um how the voices of of farmers can be
elevated
in institutions like the world bank fao
novozymes
uh as well as how their voices can be
uh accentuated in initiatives such as
the un food system summit
or in the broader climate agenda which
was touched upon earlier
so martian beginning with you briefly if
you could share your thoughts on how the
the voices
of farmers can be further emphasized
within
institutions and and international
processes
i think thanks very much sir thomas um
let me start at the global level um
i you know i already mentioned that uh
as part of the upcoming food systems
summit
i mean be very active as part of
you know putting in place the food
finance architecture
there's a finance lever there
[Music]
we are actively reaching out and working
very closely i mean with
um federations of farmers organizations
to make sure that their voice is being
heard i mean the world farmers
organization
is for instance a example of it i think
that's
very important because there are many
organizations who claim
i mean to speak on behalf of the farmers
um but if you then talk to the farmers i
mean they tell me that's often that's
not the case so
having the authentic voice of the
farmers by reaching out
i mean to membership organizations is
key
at the country level when we do
financing for the agriculture sector and
a major kind of you know ag policy
reform programs or
working with governments in um
redirecting public support along the
lines i mentioned earlier
um i always tell the ministers of
agriculture
you know if you cannot explain what
we're trying to do in the projects that
we finance to a farmer
and how it actually benefits her wallet
i mean then it's a losing proposition
so actually you know having that
perspective
to kind of think through and calculate
true i mean what those reforms
mean for farmers bullets is key
and then at the final level at the
lowest level in the um at the project
level i mean because most of the bank
financing
is channeled i mean it's all kind of
projects
i mean we take public consultation i
mean very seriously
as very part of you know of of our kind
of project preparation procedures
we work very closely with local farmers
organizations
also the funding actually is directed to
those organizations
um the kind of the the the the the
where we do the economic cost benefit
analysis of project
i mean ultimately that's calculated
based on the beneficiaries
most of the time are farmers so both at
the global country and local level
i mean we are kind of you know reaching
out at all those levels to make sure
that farmers views actually are
integrated
and that's key i mean to success back to
you thomas
thanks very much martin so tony over to
you the same question if you could
discuss uh how the the voices and
perspectives of farmers can be further
elevated in institutions such as fao and
in international processes
thank you tom well first of all that
question raises
one one issue which is well who are the
farmers we're talking about
you know the farming community is not
homogeneous
so we need to to make sure that we're
talking about heterogeneous uh
community of different backgrounds
different capacities
different knowledge i think derek was
saying that farming is the size based
profession
yes and no it depends to whom you know
there are farmers who have the
opportunity to be educated and to have
access to knowledge to digital
technology
and there are smallholder farmers
obviously who are an educated some some
are uneducated they don't have the same
level of capacity the
same level of access to knowledge and
and and
learning so when we talk about
you know the the access as you were
saying we have to to just distinguish
between the fact that we're talking
about different kind of people in
different kind of
settings and i think that's absolutely
critical so we don't give the impression
that we're talking about
farmers in general and everything we're
saying all the solutions we're talking
about they're going to apply to everyone
they want
um and the second point i want to make
again with with your question is the
fact that um
there are possibly uh two avenues
the first which is um again
farmers who have access to be involved
to be engaged
and they can be invited to to the table
you know either at
fao or other processes no problem they
can't travel they can
have access they can read they can
contribute fine
um and and those who can't and this is
the second category
then you have to find out the means of
doing that and the other means are to
use the national representative the
national policy makers
the mps the ministers and others who can
bring their voices to
to these platforms and also the ngos
ngos they play an important
part really in connecting with the local
realities with farmers
and bringing those um needs those
priorities that they have those
asks to to the platform and that's
absolutely critical
and the last point i would make
particularly in the current era where
we're talking about technology and
innovation
then we need to reach out to farmers and
listen to them it's very easy to film
these days
so you can go to any community ask the
farmers the questions
you know we're talking about change how
can we make any change if we don't know
what the farmers want how can they be
involved can
they in what circumstances and how
and also just to distinguish about
the changes we want to make some of the
changes are
big and challenging and demanding and
some changes for some small communities
just
little changes will make a huge
difference to the survivals to the
livelihood to the income
and that's absolutely critical so my my
point is
we need to be uh proactive as well to go
and find farmers and
and hear what they want to say in some
context you know they don't have
time to be involved in in global agenda
they have other worries other priorities
so we need to go and see well how can we
help you
they're never going to think whoa whoa
there is a conference on climate change
in glasgow
we better go and and take part in that
absolutely not
so we are responsible in reaching out to
those people when we talk about leaving
no
no one behind that's what it means go
and find the people
see what they want and take ownership
and help them thank you
thanks itony i think you raised some
excellent questions and made some
some very important points there as of
course did martin
um before turning to thomas i would just
like to flag that
just after promise i would like to turn
to each of our speakers
and ask them very briefly in about 30
seconds to 45 seconds
to share with the audience what their
key takeaway message would be
if the audience is to remember one thing
that each of you has said what would it
be
uh so please begin giving thought to
that but before turning to
each of you respectively i would like to
ask thomas to respond to this question
of how the
voices and perspectives of farmers can
be better
amplified within institutions or
organizations or companies
um and also if i may very briefly thomas
a secondary question for you which has
come in from lauren hirsch um
asking about what some of the key
research gaps are
still in need of investment over to you
thomas
and you can actually link a little bit
because i think one of the things that
we as kind of corporate
innovation drivers lag sometimes is
actually the engagement with with
farmers
early on to really make sure that we
develop solutions that fit into the
reality
simple application realities economic
windows of
reality because you have great lab work
but it never hits the market because
it's misunderstood the application
reality
so that's a simple uh you should be easy
but it really isn't
but we have so many as we've exemplified
today farmers that are progressive
and actually eager to engage and that
kind of engagement
is is critical and then i would would
tagline it over to the second part of
the question
of also creating these partnerships and
alliances it can be with co-ops or
individual farmers because sometimes
it's also
what is the willingness to pay if
there's not a market for methane
reduction or if there's not
a credit given for carbon capture or
soil health which is a longer-term gain
than a yield one year
well is it a is it a product concept or
not and some farmers would love to pay
for it but they can't afford it
and then you need to link it back to
policy making incentives and so forth
and coming as a joint
a representation of farmers and not as a
corporate innovator
that's being perceived to seek profit
only creates a much better
partnership for policy dialogue and so
forth so i think
that there's many of these which are
these gaps that was asked to
like soil health a methane reduction
which are nebulous
business cases because who will pay for
them
so that answers kind of that question
there's a long list of business
opportunities
which should have capital value for a
farmer but doesn't today
and we can find a way to get that via
incentives and get a fast way to market
that would be
great progress fantastic thank you very
much thomas i hope
i'm not being too ambitious here but
with the time that remains
i would really like to turn to each of
our six speakers who are still with us
to ask them in about 30 seconds to share
their key takeaway message with
our audience and if i could start with
you secretary ross
i was afraid i was going to be first and
there was so much here
two things i'm going to touch on one um
i think thomas mentioned that we're
trying to create some biological
solutions and trying to fit them into a
regulatory framework for chemistry
and i think that really is something
every country could take a look at
and two thank you zatuni for your
comments because i'm keenly aware
california ag is very diverse we have
the smallest
organic urban farms all the way to the
larger
multi-generation but the small farmer
and how do we engage on a global basis
if we really want to make a difference
that's where we're going to have to
really work together and create
partnerships thank you
thanks so much secretary ross back to
you thomas for your key takeaway
sorry me yes yeah
sorry um yes i would keep it back to the
the central point about the potential
and innovation is there it's a matter of
unleashing it and getting it in the
hands fast and an efficient way
regulatory fast tracks ways to enable
farmers to adopt
fast would be my key takeaway excellent
thanks for your brevity
uh martian over to you
thanks thanks tom um i i start um you
know by
referring to what derek said you know we
need to reward private land stewards who
protect i mean
common public goods so my takeaway is
that you know
we need to kind of provide farmers the
right incentives to do so and when it
comes to
uh making farmers better agents
of change in greeting agriculture i
think we need to provide them
the right incentives so that we actually
can move to a situation
where we it's where it's recognizing
where we redefine
what it is to be a farmer in the 21st
century i mean not just a producer of
food
but also a provider of ecosystem
services and this would be revenue
streams
attached to that thank you martian
um is itunes over to you in 30 seconds
or less please
thank you tom what three three points i
would say the first one is
definitely to include smallholder
farmers and to listen to them
the second point is to recognize the
importance of
indigenous and local knowledge and the
third point i would make was within
touch on its match actually
is changing models but also changing our
mindsets
everyone thank you thanks itune
i think it's only right and fitting that
our farmer should have the the final
word
as it were so if i could turn to derrick
and then doug
each in about 30 seconds or less please
uh derek over to you
thank you i think the sentiment from
farmers everywhere is they feel
like the villain and and absent from a
lot of these conversations
that's simply unacceptable not only is
the farmer
play a critical role but we have a lot
to be proud of
in the food supply that we provide
everybody and not only is the farmer the
you know not the villain but but but
critical
to the solution and the answers lie on
the farm
and so um again i i appreciate the
opportunity to share our thoughts and
you could have had
hundreds of thousands of farmers from
around the world participate in this
discussion and you have had
equally diverse and interesting
perspectives from each one of them
thank you derek doug over to you yeah
on a couple of these topics you know
some of the organizations are doing this
uh we built a 40 million dollar research
facility to
to study these type of things uh
greenhouses the whole work sorghum is
working on it they're even doing virtual
reality work with international markets
international grains program was
developed in kansas and at kansas state
university
in connection with about seven or eight
different commodities
to address these issues so farmers are
reaching out doing a lot of this
i think a lot of these governmental
entities and organizations are not
reaching out to the farmers like myself
and others
because that work is being done and
but my final takeaway is just include
the farmers in these rules
because we all got to do it and as much
as possible
the best way to do that is by making the
carbon
a free market system because of its free
market system as eluded by some of the
others
the price of that carbon capture could
go up and it will naturally happen
thank you so much for today thank you
very much doug i would now like to turn
the floor back
over to our moderator trolls
thank you so much tom and thank you to
the audience for all your excellent
questions and uh to our panel and
speakers for a very insight
full conversation and thank you tom for
moderating it
and thank you for being the mastermind
behind this event tom and fao did most
of the heavy lifting behind this event
so hats off to you guys
and now i would like to hand out the
floor to vimlendra from fao once again
this time for some concluding remarks
remember the floor is yours
thank you trolls and you've been quite
modest i think
the embassy really took it upon
themselves to make sure that we
have the event as successful as we did
have it today so
it was a extremely engrossing discussion
and
i think even to expect to be able to do
justice and summarize what we heard in
five minutes
i think it's beyond my capacity but
i will try and uh
bring out the main issues which i heard
today
both from policymakers the
technical people looking at the global
issues and definitely from the farming
community represented by
three farmers online today
uh i learned a lot
and i realized that more productive and
resilient
agriculture will require transformation
and management of natural resources
and higher efficiency of in use of these
resources
and inputs for production we heard uh
to start with we heard from sauron
sannega that farmers hold the key and
this point got reiterated again and
again
uh including till the very last in in
take away messages
that they hold the key and they will be
the one who will have to lead the front
transition he also emphasized the need
for a very effective partnership
and strong r d along with strong
incentives for farmers to bring about
this transition
uh secretary kevin rose thank you for
reminding us that agriculture will
perhaps
be the first and best way to begin
getting some wins in climate area
and your emphasis on keeping
sustainability and biodiversity
from center in our policy prescriptions
the greening of agriculture will also
present an
almost innovation challenge of producing
more food and fiber without relying
on most of the technological mainstays
of productivity gains
of the past so we need to innovate and
we saw how andre nargo has led his
organization
sustainable practices through biogas
plans digital feed chain climate check
etc
and andre we totally agree with you
you're definitely not part of the
problem you are the solution going
forward
a new demand is also being placed on
agriculture
and it has been asked to replace
environmentally damaging products and
protect biodiversity
and mitigate climate change as well as
address livelihoods and lifestyles
and what better way to go ahead with
this than to follow the initiatives
are shown by bulls farming company and
the kiesling farms
which see farms not just as a place to
grow but also to make
farms work as a carbon sink as a habitat
to promote biodiversity
and also a place to grow human resources
so the need to do all this
and they've argued very strongly is to
mention
is to maintain the farming remains as
remunerative activity
we heard the community talk again and
again about
how farming is no more
a very remunerative activity and how the
youth is turning away from it so thank
you so toony and martine for bringing a
global perspective to it
uh mr tooney he told us about fao's
effort at integrating farmers voice the
global agenda
and also in handholding farming
community at country level to make
to take to climate smart agriculture
and thank you for emphasizing once again
the need to remember smallholder farmers
because
many times in our debate in north
america we tend to focus on what farming
is in and around
this part of the world but to remember
the 98 percent of the farming community
is still farms and 10 hectares and less
and your emphasis on being grounded in
our traditional knowledge
but looking forward to the future and
having the capacity
and the courage to embrace modern
science and evidence
martin thank you so much for explaining
so well the need to better apply and
target
public resources going into agriculture
worldwide
uh can the 700 billion dollars be used
much better can they be repurposed
i think that's a extremely uh strong
phrase how do we repurpose the 700
billion going in
to ensure that they actually end up
incentivizing farmers to invest in green
technology and sustainable farming
and that will require a lot of
coordination with policymakers policy
framers
across the globe and especially in the
global south thank you for spotlighting
that farmers are in the
front line of climate change and the
need to understand that they are the
victims and not the cause
thomas you so rightly highlighted the
importance of
biological solutions for agriculture and
food value chains and the fact that they
exist
and the need to change the regulatory
framework to ensure
that the land lab to land transfer
happens extremely fast
and the need for understanding the
requirements
the economic reality the
implementational reality
of bringing modern science to to the
land
so if we take all this together and
summarize
i think i'm being too ambitious to put
it bring it in one sentence or two
sentences but i would say that the
potential of
new science innovation knowledge
technology and partnership
to contribute to sustainable and green
agriculture
will depend on policy finding a way
to manage these changes in a way
that provides a balanced outcome for the
society and the environment
and ends up help incentivize the farmers
to make the transition so it it the
policy has to give the right signal
and with that signal and partnership and
knowledge and innovation
and science and finance at an end we
need to go forward
always keeping the farmer as the focus
point as the focal point
and ensuring that he is front center of
all our policy making
so as we close this discussion today i
think we need to take
these lessons home and we need to help
promote the urgent need to transition to
green and sustainable agriculture
i'm sure all of you would have taken
your own
lessons from the various points made by
our speakers and i
would end by thanking all of them to
have taken time out of their business
and attend this help us
understand the issue with their ideas
their thoughts and their perspectives
thank you so much and back to you trolls
thank you so much vimelendra as always
on the point
um and that concludes today's special
event
i think it has been a very interesting
conversation and a much needed one
we have less than 10 years to reach the
sustainable
development goals and some of the
ambitious national goals for co2
reduction
the clock is ticking and even as we are
still in a dire situation with covet
around the globe
there is hope as we have heard today
from farmers from government global
organizations
private sectors there is a great
potential that can be unlocked
and that farmers and other actors in the
supply chain around them can adapt and
engage
with agility in a transformation for a
more sustainable future
so once again thank you so much all of
the speakers for your great
contributions
and thank you to all the audience for
for listening in we're sorry we couldn't
take any more of your
very good questions you have been a very
active audience so thank you so much
but i'm sure the conversation continues
it needs to continue
and so thank you so much all of you and
have a nice rest of your day
thank you
you